- All right, Georgetta.
- Yes?
- [Interviewer] Georgetta,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Georgetta] I'm from Watts, California.
- [Interviewer] And you grew
up with both your parents?
- [Georgetta] Yes.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- Very good.
- [Interviewer] You had a nice childhood?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
And tell me where your life went
after you left your parents.
- Well, my mom passed away.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- My mom passed away from colon cancer.
And there's eight boys and
two girls, I'm the baby.
It's two boys on my dad's
side and six on my mom's side.
It was very good.
My mom had the house for us.
You know? It was for us.
So she had colon cancer, she was sick.
I was still on her side.
And that colon cancer, I
didn't know nothing about it.
I didn't know nothing about it.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was around about 16,
no, about 15. I was 15.
I was 15, I was still in junior high.
And when I found out, I was
coming home from school one day,
and I was going to her room
and I heard my brother and her talking,
and she was telling my brother
that she was tired and she was sick.
I didn't realize it until
she was taking fucking
pain pills and stuff.
You know what I mean? She
was taking pain pills.
I wonder why she was taking pain pills.
One day, my sister, it's just two girls,
my older sister, she went
and got her some Somas
and they was generic.
And she took the Somas,
and her tongue started
swelling up in her mouth!
I'm like, wow! Mom what's wrong?
You know what I mean?
So they was generic, you know,
and they wasn't originally for her pain,
you know what I mean? I didn't know.
You know what I mean? I
didn't know nothing about it.
You know what I mean?
And it hurt my heart.
You feel me? It really did.
And didn't nobody let me
know nothing about nothing.
They weren't gonna let me know nothing
'cause I'm the baby of the family.
You know what I mean?
So they didn't let me know nothing.
So after she passed, my
dad, no, I paid the last
I paid the last, I paid the
last deeds of the house,
the last taxes of the house.
So my dad asked me did I want to be the,
did I wanna be the, you know,
the provider of the house.
And I told him, no.
My sister, she had a friend or whatever.
You know, he was good to the
family or whatever, you know?
So he gave him to deed to the house.
You know, but I still was in the house.
You know what I mean? I had my mom's room.
Did nobody want to go in my mom's room.
Did nobody want to go in there.
Nobody didn't want to go in there.
After the funeral,
nobody would go in there,
or nothing. I went in the room.
Know what I mean, nobody
want to go in there.
My auntie, nobody wanted to go in there.
I went in the room, I stayed in the room.
One night, I just woke up,
I couldn't move or nothing.
And I woke up, and I see her
standing in the bathroom door.
I see her standing there.
You know, I see her standing there
I mean, she was in the house.
Know what I mean, see,
she was in the house.
You know? She was in the house.
I stayed in her room.
So when my brother got out of prison,
and everything went wrong or whatever,
and I told my dad, "sell the property.
Sell it, sell it, because no, sell it."
So he sold it. He gave us
a thousand dollars a piece.
So my sister's oldest son
found us a house in San Bernardino.
So me and my sister
and her three kids
from her first generation of kids.
So her first generation of kids
her baby boy, my nephew,
my favorite nephew.
He got killed at 84th and Western.
He got killed on 84th and Western.
It was all a little
gang banging and stuff.
Hell I mean...Wow!
That's right. Yeah. I mean it is,
it's been a tragedy.
It's really been a tragedy.
It really has--
(voice breaking)
it really has,
and I miss my mom so much.
I miss my mom so much.
I miss- I miss her so,
I miss my her so much.
I do--
(Georgetta gasping)
My dad solved the problem,
he moved to San Bernardino.
Lived in San Bernardino
for about five years.
Met my, my, you know, I was
born and raised out in Watts,
so I had to come back to Watts,
you know, for my health, I have HIV.
I have HIV, okay? I have HIV.
So I got back here, you know what I mean?
And it's a tragedy I mean that we have.
I was here, I mean, in Watts.
And I've been going through it,
and I was homeless and...
I was homeless in Watts.
And I caught Pneumonia in Watts,
I almost died in Watts.
I was up under a bridge
on Compton and Imperial,
up under the bridge.
And my brother told me, he
came and got me, helped me.
I've been here, I've been-I've
been I've been at Eugene.
I've been at Eugene for four years.
You know what I mean? I mean...
Oh boy. It's been a tragedy.
It's getting a little
better. You know what I mean?
I have eight sib...eight
boys and two girls.
I got six on my mom's side.
And there's two on my dad's side.
And there's one of them that
me and him really clash.
We used to boost together.
You know what I mean?
We used to boost together,
we used to boost together,
but now it's all...
I mean it's all right
now, you know, I'll be--
- [Interviewer] Georgetta, do
you have children of your own?
- I have four. I have two girls, two boys.
- [Interviewer] And did you raise them?
- Yeah. I mean, not really,
but, I mean but I was there for them.
You know what I mean? I
was there. I was there.
At my first kid. You know
what I mean? I was there.
You know what I mean? I mean, I was there.
- [Interviewer] Georgetta,
what is your drug?
- Crack cocaine.
- [Interviewer] And what age were you
when you started with that?
- I was like 21.
- [Interviewer] 21?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how long have you
been down here on Skid Row?
- I've been here four years.
- [Interviewer] How many?
- Four. Four years.
- [Interviewer] Four years?
- In Eugene Hotel.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I've been here four years.
My brother, my one, my brother
helped me get the place here.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money now?
- Nothing. I get year
help, I get year help.
- [Interviewer] You're not dating guys
or anything like that?
- No, no, no.
- [Interviewer] You never did that?
- No, I mean, yes I have. Yes I have.
I have in the past, yes
I have. Yeah, I have.
And it's been tragic.
You see this on my nose
here? On my nose here?
I was pregnant with my last son.
I was seven and a half months pregnant.
My godmother's staying in Bixby North.
I was coming from her
home, in the evening.
I was passing through,
going down Compton Avenue
and there's an alley there.
Before I get from the alley,
there was a youngster.
He propositioned me, and he see me.
I tell him, "I'm pregnant."
You know what I mean?
Well, he, she sees that,
he cuz', he said, "I apologize."
After that, I don't know what happened.
When I woke up, all, I
don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened.
When I woke up, I was laying down.
I was out on my back. I was down.
I ain't even know my face was messed up.
I ain't even know. My face was so bad.
My face was bad! It was really bad!
It was fucking bad! It was bad!
All I was worried about was my baby!
I didn't care nothing about nothing else!
(crying)
I was worried about my baby.
(weeping)
I couldn't feel nothing, then.
And when I came to, everybody was over me
I mean everybody was over me,
my pants were halfway
down, he take my money.
Everything was busted wide open.
Everything was just hanging out,
My chin right here, this was wide open.
My nose was wide open.
And I couldn't call my
family for about two days.
But I'm so, just, set back.
(gasping)
And when it came to, me and my brother,
when we were boosting, we used to sell it,
the Modern Cosmetics.
I mean, yeah, I mean...
I remember his face, I remember his face.
I remember his face.
(gasping)
And three weeks later, I said
it when I tell my brother,
I said "that's him right there."
And he approached me again
and I tell my brother,
I say "that's him right there.
That's him right there."
They had to leave, I could,
right there, they had to leave.
It was so bad. It was so bad.
I just thank God for
my life and my brother.
(gasping)
And for my family for today, I do.
I do. I do.
Down here, it's nothing down here.
They just don't, they
don't have no unions here
or nothing for you each other. Nothing.
Excuse me. They don't have
nothing for each other.
Nothing, man. I mean, I mean...
I turned 50 years old, December the 14th.
Nobody helped me.
I don't know... I just
miss my mom so much.
I miss my mom, I do.
I miss my mom so much. I do.
I miss my mom a lot, I do.
I miss my mom so much.
She was everything to me.
Everything to me. Everything.
- [Interviewer] Georgetta,
do you talk with your children?
- Yes. I talk to them every day.
I talk to them every day, every day.
I talk to them every day.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any plans for your future?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any plans for your future?
- I mean, I'm just, I'm just going,
I'm just going to have to,
I'm just going to stick it out.
You know what I mean?
I just thank God I have
a roof over my head.
I have a brother that looks out for me.
You know what I mean? I love him so much.
You know, me and him, we
understand each other.
Out of all my eight brothers,
me and him, we understand each other,
you know what I mean?
He looks out for me, you know what I mean?
He got my EBT card and he-
he follows up and he
brings my groceries to me.
He paid my rent for me and all that.
You know what I mean?
I mean, you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Do you
think there's any chance
that you'll get off the crack?
- I mean...yeah.
I'm going to go back to the program again.
I'll go back and after this time,
I'm through. I'm through.
I just, yeah, I'm through,
I mean I'm through, through, through.
I can't do it. I'm 50 years old.
Can't do it no more. Can't do it.
When I go through the program,
I want to change my environment.
You know what I mean?
I already knew I want my, I
want to change my environment.
Know what I mean?
I want to change my environment.
I miss my mom so much.
I miss her so much. I do.
Oh man. I miss her so much.
I talk to her every day.
I miss her so much.
Oh man, I miss my mamma so much, I do.
Oh man, I miss her so much.
I do, man I miss her so much.
That colon cancer, ended her up bad,
ended her up so bad, ended her up bad.
I mean, wow, man!
I miss her so much.
Oh man.
(sobbing)
I miss her so much, I do,
I miss my mom so much.
I swear I do, I miss her so much.
Oh, man.
Oh man, I miss her so much.
I think about her everyday.
I think about her everyday, everyday.